is the Apple watch Ultra really worth
800 or should you just get the series 8
instead well that's exactly what we're
gonna answer by comparing everything
from the design the sizes the new
display the battery life the new
speakers and microphones exclusive
features and more now let's be honest
guys I think most people that are gonna
be buying this watch are not crazy Ultra
Runners uh climbers or divers even
though some of them will that is such an
amazing graphic here showing off that
you want to be adventurous with it but I
think most people just want something
new the Apple watch has been similar for
so long we finally have a change and of
course the better battery life now it's
cool that they switched up the packaging
it's still split like that all right we
got it opened up right here and
oh that's big that is pretty big that is
pretty big oh man all right let's get
this bad boy out of here okay that's a
little heavier than I thought is it this
titanium is supposed to be light
oh it definitely has some weight to this
thing I looked it up and it is almost 60
heavier than my series 8 large Apple
watch and you know what I think it's
probably heavier than this whole setup
with my pataka carbon fiber band that is
super lightweight let's feel this oh my
goodness yavidim I think it is heavier
overall that is crazy all right you know
what let me go ahead and try it on Apple
said that the ultra is compatible with
previous watch bands including the
series eight so hopefully this is going
to be nice and lightweight let's go
ahead and try it on thankfully this
thing has a magnetic clasp there you go
I definitely feel the weight but it's
not too bad maybe the watch band is
helping because it's made from real
carbon fiber instead of plastic with a
thin sheet or fake painted so it weighs
almost nothing if you guys like this you
guys could check it out I'll link it
down below uh but the next thing I'm
noticing is just that size difference
not only that this thing is like didn't
you see
let me grab the loop uh we also have the
charger it is a braided cable now the
ultra is the only one that has that so
that's nice I got the green Alpine Loop
but I really wanted the trail one they
just sold out insanely fast let's pull
it out oh that color looks a little
different in person this thing has a
little bit of stretch and of course you
have this clasp here let's pop this
thing on here it has these bumps they
got to pull up and then we'll pull this
thing through and come on here
all right and look at that guys my
goodness not only is it larger obviously
but that thickness difference is pretty
substantial now I also bought an ultra
for my wife she's been using an older
one for a while she's very active I
think it's going to be too big and too
thick for her now before I set it up I
notice a couple of things obviously we
have a flat screen with this raised kind
of edge that sticks out makes the watch
look a little thinner than it actually
is but this Edge is sharp I was like
what is this on the top corner and it's
actually my fingernail getting scratched
off you do not want to put this on your
iPhone's screen or have it touched
anything that you don't want to scratch
up here's my old donor phone let's see
this oh my goodness you just hear that
scratching going on the series 8 has
these rounded edges super smooth that
meets with the glass this thing will not
scratch your phone your furniture or
anything else now some people mention
that even though the ultra has a larger
screen you don't see more so so here I
adjusted both to the same text size and
do the search and as you guys could see
on the ultra we see the open Button
where on the series 8 you actually have
to scroll down to be able to see it and
press it one thing I noticed is that the
ultra's bezel is a lot more noticeable
because it has a flat screen instead of
the series 8 which curves the glass all
the way to the side where it meets the
aluminum but the plus side to that is
that the ultra has this raised lip
around the screen which is going to
protect the screen from hitting objects
and this thing also has a sapphire
display whereas a series 8 aluminum uses
ion X glass which sounds cool but it's
not that durable both my wife and my son
have scratches on this screen and of
course the aluminum also scratches
easily compared to the titanium here
which is a lot more durable and that's
probably why we only have a single color
that is unpainted titanium just so you
don't scratch that off which I already
have a small scratch and aluminum here
and the glass class of the series 8. so
in general the ultra is a lot more
durable looking at the backs now you
guys see those screws instead of just
having glue applied and with that we
have doubled the water resistance it's
just a more extreme sport watch overall
and looking at the sides now instead of
just having this digital Crown that's
thin we have this fat one and we have
this Crown guard all around it so you
don't accidentally bump it the crown has
these deeper grooves and one thing I
noticed is that the haptics do feel
stronger on the ultra with that we have
our button here that protrudes so it's
easy to press even if you have gloves on
one thing that's a first on an Apple
Watch is these bands right below the top
of the display the previous Apple
watches didn't have that at all and this
new Ultra has dual GPS which is awesome
I wish I could give that to my kids
because sometimes I open up find my and
I'll see this Wide Circle or I will see
a closer Circle but then hop around and
I thought my kid left somewhere from
their friend's house but then it updated
back there so having the extra accuracy
of the dual GPS is really nice and
another first is that additional action
button on that left hand side in
International Orange uh if you press
that you can give you a bunch of
different things I set mine up to be a
flashlight so as soon as I press it bam
that is getting bright right there you
can also change it to a variety of
different things like working out using
waypoints and more now if you hold it
down it's going to give you a pop-up for
your shortcut and then we have the siren
right here so let's go ahead and test
that out
interesting all right it's getting loud
each time
wow wow
I gotta say it's not as loud as I
thought it would be
Apple did say that it will carry very
far so maybe it's the frequency but it
doesn't sound that loud now if you guys
look the speaker Grill on here is pretty
massive compared to this little slot so
let's play something and hear how it
sounds
[Music]
it's a lot louder on the ultra so if
you're a noisy environment you're taking
a phone call it's gonna be a lot easier
to hear now with that let's cover the
microphones the ultra has three of them
one on the left side and two on the
right whereas a series a only has one
let's go ahead and do a test this is the
microphone quality of the Apple Watch
series 8 and this is the quality of the
Ultras three microphones in a room that
doesn't have too much noise now I want
to turn on some background noise from a
cafe just to mimic being in a louder
environment this is a series 8
microphone quality if you're in a noisy
environment and this is the Apple watch
ultra's microphones in a noisy
environment we took a listen to the
recordings and I have to be honest I
think that the series 8 sounds better in
both scenarios you have a little bit
more clarity a little bit more bass in
the microphones I don't know how Apple
chooses which one to use maybe use the
one on the other side and maybe there'd
be a bigger difference if you're say in
the wind and the other mic will kick on
but overall I was expecting a bigger
difference now the other thing we
haven't mentioned is the brightness of
the displays the series 8 is rated for a
thousand its maximum compared to 2000
for the ultra you guys can see that's a
big difference when I open up the
flashlight app now with normal usage
you're not really going to see a
difference because the ultra is capped
just like the newer iPhones but if
you're outside and you're in direct
lighting you do notice the extra
brightness and that can come in handy
and now I want to talk about battery
life which is the biggest reason why I
want the ultra now not everybody needs
36 hours of battery life which is double
what the series a gives you but one
thing you have to think about is that
two three years down the line the
battery life degrades on these Apple
watches and my current Apple watch
doesn't even make it through a full day
every night now before I go to bed it
dies on me and that's not even counting
doing a long workout or when you're
tracking things just because the battery
is degraded so having the extra capacity
is great not only to not have to charge
every day or go on trips and doing long
workouts but just the fact that it's
going to last you a lot longer now as
far as prices a lot of people say the
ultra is double the cost of the series 8
and that is simply not true first off
the larger size 45 millimeter series 8
which competes with it well that's more
expensive than the base and then if you
add cellular which the ultra has that
makes it even more expensive so the
difference is only 270 dollars which is
still a lot but it's not double the
price now with that the ultra uses
sapphire glass as well so if you want to
get a durable series 8 that won't
scratch the screen and the aluminum
won't scratch then you have to spend
even more money so now if you're getting
one that has a better band anything
other than the cheapest one you're
spending 800 bucks the same price as the
ultra so with that said which one should
you buy honestly I think that if you are
okay with the larger size and this
styling you should absolutely get the
ultra because you get a lot better
battery life a nicer display a lot more
extra features for example the depth
sensor that I didn't mention earlier the
action button you have the better GPS
and all of the other things compared to
the series 8 which is an older design
now it will be updated in the future and
especially if you're going to upgrade to
Cellular or stainless steel the ultra is
a killer value now who should buy the
series 8 well obviously we have the size
and weight difference but with that if
you like the nice Sleek design that
doesn't look super sporty if you want
something that's going to be thin on
your wrist if you want to have the
choice of colors and materials and of
course if you don't need the cellular
and you want to buy aluminum anyways
it's a much lower price point but with
that I would say just go ahead and pick
up a series seven because there's very
little differences you can buy those
deeply discounted so you guys can go
ahead and check out that video right
there our comparison of the eight versus
the 7 and the SE click that Circle above
to subscribe to see my follow-up review
of the ultra and if I'm going to stick
with it long term this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]